- I hear your hobby these days though,
I mean, I know after all it's
been a pandemic or whatever
and I hear your hobbies lately
have been kind of nerdy.
So I'm very excited to know.
- I feel my hobbies were always nerdy.
I did grow up like reading graphic novels.
And my older sister was
really into "X-Men" comics.
And so I got into comics young.
- I love "X-Men".
- I'm a big reader also just in general.
So I'm not usually on TV a lot,
like watching TV or watching movies.
I do a lot of reading.
Super dorky.
- [Kelly] Oh, right on.
- But--
- Me too.
- One of my favorite things
that everyone gives me
a hard time about, and
I'm dying to go there
as soon as I can to Harry
Potterland and Universal.
I am a crazy Harry Potter
- I'm a Gryffindor.
- I'm, obvy.
- [Kelly] You're a Gryffindor?
- [Megan] Yeah, I a Gryffindor too.
- [Kelly] Okay, I have the whole thing.
- Do you have a cape?
A scarf?
- [Kelly] I have a cape,
the scarf, the wand, the--
- Do you have a coffee mug?
- I have everything, Megan.
- [Megan] Okay.
- I'm literally, I just
took my kids to Legoland
and I will tell you this, I
am the child of the group.
I have a five and six-year-old.
I am the toddler of the group.
I get so excited, like way
more excited than they get.
- It's actually super divisive.
Like when you do your house
which house you're in,
like amongst your family.
'Cause anyone that gets sorted into--
- [Kelly] Slytherin?
(audience laughing)
- Is very upset about it.
- I was kinda, I love Gryffindor.
I was kinda bummed because
I was so basic about it.
I knew I was gonna to be a Gryffindor.
I don't know, I was kinda
like, "All right, all right."
- Right, courageous, adventurous?
(laughing) That's Harry house.
- She's like these
are the things we are.
Do you get more excited
than your boys or do they?
- They don't care yet, they're too young.
- They don't understand--
- [Kelly] Oh, see,
my kids are kinda--
- But they understand that I'm obsessed.
So every gift they get me for Mother's Day
or Christmas is Harry Potter themed.
So I get Harry Potter mugs
or Harry Potter journals
or I got like a quill for my birthday.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Yeah.
- Oh, I full on got an owl.
Whatever, not a real one.